now millions of american children are
returning to school this morning in the
face of a high jump in new cova cases
across much of the country most schools
are doing in-person classes but some
school districts are teaching remotely
the number of new cases reported in the
u.s last week hit an all-time high
nearly half a million in one day meg
oliver is in paterson new jersey where
students are staying home meg good
morning
nate good morning patterson is one of
several new jersey school districts
opting for a remote start this winter
while they are firmly in the minority
right now some teachers unions are
hoping that their districts follow suit
especially in hard-hit cities like new
york
the omicron outbreak shows no signs of
slowing down in new york city new cases
jumped 218 percent in just two weeks
hospitalizations up 148 percent to keep
schools open the city is sending an
additional 2 million test kits into
schools and doubling the number of
students tested each week but the
teachers union is asking for in-person
learning to be put on pause and teachers
like camille eterno are urging the mayor
to listen
i recognize the need for students to be
present in the buildings but i'm also
cognizant of the fact that
if we're all bunched up together and we
get sick we're not going to be there
anyway
only about 100 of the nation's over 13
000 school districts are opting for
virtual learning this winter despite
surging case numbers in washington d.c
the number of new cases jumped 331
percent over the last two weeks and city
officials extended winter break by just
two days so all students had time to get
tested
about one in four tests are coming back
positive in miami-dade county where
schools are also opening on time i
believe even with omicron our default
should be in person learning for all
students across the country on face the
nation sunday education secretary miguel
cardona told cbs news's margaret brennan
that the bide administration is helping
school districts secure more tests to
keep classrooms open i still believe
very firmly and very passionately not
only as an educator but as a parent that
our students belong in the classroom and
we can do it safely
the secretary says that includes
mitigation strategies like mask wearing
vaccines for kids who are eligible and
social distancing now on sunday dr
anthony fauci said the cdc received some
blowback for their newest covet
isolation policy the guideline does not
require a negative test to exit that
five day period dr fauci says they may
reconsider requiring it gail
all right meg thank you very much